this is a production of Cornell
University
hey thanks for the introduction Tony uh
so I'm really glad to be here today uh
this is uh my first time talking at sips
in general
um since my job talk two years ago and
so I'm excited to tell you about some of
the things that I've been working on
since then
so uh so I thought I'd start by giving
you a little bit of a professional
introduction to who I am since I haven't
met many of you before so I am a plant
population and Community ecologist by
training and my dissertation was on
range expansion of plants in response to
climate change
what did that work I developed a couple
of research teams including uh creating
models of ecological processes for
individual plants
and then scaling those models to
populations and landscapes
did this though as a graduate student I
I eventually realized that I didn't want
to just be creating this knowledge I
also wanted to be applying it and so
since then I've been working on another
research theme which includes
using these models uh if I can get the
the pointer right up here uh using these
types of models uh to optimize health
related ecosystem services and business
services
this has brought me from the remote
forests of Northern Michigan it's a more
urban Landscapes and I've also turned my
focus more from plant demography to
plant human interactions
for example shade so right now in Austin
it is where this photo is from it is
right now today it is 92 degrees there
honestly a little jealous uh at the
moment but it is so in that context
shade matters an awful lot
so we have uh truths like this one
providing shade and now let's zoom out
and look at that same tree from above
and here it is
um and what we can do is we can model
these ecosystem services like shade uh
and for example we can include things
like the the structure of the the trees
like they're three-dimensional shapes as
well as the trajectory of the sun across
the sky to model something like shade
over the course of a day so here's an
example of a little animation of shade
now because this is built with remote
sensing data we can then scale this up
to a neighborhood or Municipal scales
these models help us to capture how
these different ecosystem services and
disk Services uh vary and when it comes
to something like shade we have
variation from one species to another
for example the
a big oak tree that's going to produce
way more safe than a little crepe myrtle
tree but there's also these important
differences between species based on
their biology so for example Live Oak
keeps its leaves throughout the winter
whereas Shumard Oak is deciduous and so
we need to understand these little
pieces of the biology in order to create
good models and in turn
leverage this information to do a better
job of optimizing things like shade
and so uh this
so this is the type of question that I
look at uh things like can we use these
differences and shade provisioning from
one type of tree to another uh in order
to do things like keep people out of the
emergency department during heat waves
so I'm starting up a project right now
on this exact question and in it uh we
are doing things like quantifying where
trees are throughout New York City as
well as how different types of trees
provide cooling either through shade or
evapotranspiration things like that we
are then plugging that information into
a municipal scale climate models and
then uh taking that to understand heat
exposure for people and uh and assessing
how that heat exposure results in
emergency department visits through
epidemiological analysis uh and
ultimately with that type of information
we can create things like Risk maps of
where somebody is most likely to end up
going to the the hospital tour for a
heat related morbidity and since all of
this is integrated throughout uh we have
the the potential to play around here
and see what happens if if we were to
have more trees of this type in one
neighborhood or more of them in a
different type in that neighborhood and
so ultimately this gives us a way to
understand what's going on and to see
what will happen if we pop if we pull
different policy levers like planting
more of one type of tree versus another
so this is a project that I'm working on
with a couple of collaborators and I'd
just like to to take a moment to thank
arnab and XI who are over in Wild
Cornell and Engineering respectively and
with these kinds of projects they're
just way too big to deal with it all on
your own so it's really emphasizes the
importance of interdisciplinary
approaches and collaboration
what I'm going to do now is shift over
to a different type of interaction that
we have with plants and that is through
Airborne pollen
now uh almost all gymnosperms and about
10 of angiosperms are wind pollinated so
they release their pollen into the air
and hope that it gets to the next Plant
this is important for all sorts of
things whether you're talking about crop
pollination or the spread of herbicide
resistance genes and weeds but today I'm
going to be focusing in on the public
health relevant aspect of this which is
through allergies
so
I got really interested in this topic
after grad school and ended up doing a
postdoc at the school of Public Health
at the University of Michigan where I
developed a municipal scale model of
Airborne pollen uh and I approached this
by doing things like
figuring out how much pollen a plant
produces as a function of its size so a
lot of elementric equation development
and a lot of also mapping of these
plants with remote sensing and field
studies as well as developing
phenological models and then I threw all
of these together to get things like
this
which are estimates of pollen release on
particular days based on the individual
trees how much pollen they're creating
and when they're releasing it and so
this model here shows you and pollen
release over the course of a season and
these are for oak trees I suppose this
one is the spring of 2017
and so you can see this variation over
both space and time
when it comes to pollen release
this also is important to a Airborne
pollen concentrations and sometimes
assume that just because pollen can blow
long distances that it will but it turns
out based on this work that the uh that
uh where there's a lot more pollen
production
shown on x-axis here uh there's a lot
more pollen in the air on the y-axis and
this is intuitive it's hardly surprising
there's more pollen near the plants that
are releasing it but it's also really
important because it gives us a way of
understanding the marginal effect of a
particular plant on something like
pollen exposure
but this was just a model for an
individual City and plus I already told
at least some of you all about this
project so I want to move on
um and scale this up and so after I
finished that project I moved out to
Texas specifically to the University of
Texas Texas at Austin where I did
another postdoc working with Elizabeth
matsumi and Sean and John
there I focused in on juniperous ashii
which is sometimes called mountain cedar
blueberry Juniper uh
and it has I think about six common
names or so but what sticks with it um
is not so much any of those names as the
fact that it is a prodigious producer of
allergenic pollen in fact the locals in
Central Texas uh call it Cedar fever
when they're exposed to its pollen
because it produces so many allergic
symptoms things like sinus pressure
itchy eyes
um it this thing is probably the most
heated species in Texas no small feet
it is also abundant in that region now
here's a map of its distribution there
and you the the darker red colors
indicate where it's the highest density
in many of these places it's the most uh
common tree species and this whole area
is also
um it's home to about 14 million people
or so I think that would make it the
fifth largest state in the U.S just this
one area here it houses San Antonio
Austin the Dallas Fort Worth Metro areas
and so there are a lot of people which
are affected by falling from this tree
this photo on your left shows just one
little twig and all of those are
individual pollen cones uh and a big
nipperus ashii tree can produce
literally millions of these things
and inside each one of these pollen
cones there can be as many as about half
a million pollen grains just to give you
some perspective for somebody who's
really sensitized to this stuff it can
take as few as like 15 or 20 pollen
grains per cubic meter of air to begin
an allergic reaction so
um you can imagine the suffering that
this causes
understandably people care an awful lot
about knowing when this is going to be
in the air and where and so there's a
whole network of pollen monitoring
stations
um here are some that are in this area
but the pollen monitoring Network run by
the national allergy Bureau has about 80
pollen monitoring stations in the U.S
the closest one to us here in Ithaca is
in Rochester
so let's zoom in on one of those and
I'll tell you a little bit about how it
works so this is Austin and then if we
so this is downtown Austin here and then
about 25 miles away in Georgetown is the
nearest pollen monitoring station
up on their roof they have a sampler uh
that looks something like this and a few
times a week somebody goes up to that
rooftop takes out a slide or the
adhesive tape counts all of the pollen
grains on their manually identifies them
and then reports that the concentration
to the media
however
um
that is
that information that they report is
often it's in the best case over the
previous 24 hours and it's also from one
single rooftop that's pretty far away
from where most people live and so what
does this mean if you live in say East
Austin it means that you may not have
the information that you need to make
good decisions it may mean that you're
uh you don't have the the information to
decide whether you should go for a run
that day or shut your windows or turn on
your air filters things like that and it
also means that you don't have the the
guidance necessary to decide whether you
should take your medication ahead of
time because a lot of these uh require
24 to 48 hours to reach full efficacy
so
a lot of people have asked me how good
are the commercial pollen forecasts
right because you can just open up any
of the weather apps on your phone and
it'll give you a forecast it'll tell you
what's going on right where you are
right at that moment and so I really was
wondering about that too and so this
past summer and now this fall I've been
working with a couple of folks uh
including Stark who's in the audience
there
um and we've been trying to do this
systematically uh and so we're
developing a approach to pulling in all
of this information from all these
different uh websites using their apis
scraping uh their websites all of that
so and then comparing that to the
empirical pollen measurements
we're still in a uh we haven't launched
quite yet hopefully within the next
couple of weeks but we did a little bit
of manual uh curation of some of the
state and I just want to show you that
as just like little teaser uh so in this
figure here the date is on the x-axis
and the the pollen index is on the
y-axis and each of these lines are one
of the different commercial pollen
forecast providers
oh you'll notice that they go all over
the place now I want to
show you this line here which is the
actual data and even though this is
pretty preliminary I think it gives you
a pretty good sense of why we need to do
better
so what we have now is this sparse
network of monitoring stations I'd argue
that what we need is a different system
uh that is both geographically
comprehensive that is transparent and
accurate and also gives us a way to
incorporate the underlying biology into
these predictions so we can produce good
near-term and long-term forecasts
with that type of information we could
help people avoid pollen hot spots we
could tell them when to take their
medication and we'd also be able to get
a better sense of the overall Public
Health impacts of pollen exposure
so the goal with my post thought was to
create these models of Airborne pollen
concentrations for this species of
juniper and then to both assess its
effects on public health and ultimately
to figure out what we can do to make
this situation a little bit better
there's a bunch of different pieces of
this project including
things like figuring out where these
trees are how much pollen are they
releasing when are they releasing it
it's uh there's a ton of different
pieces of it I'm just going to tell you
about a couple of them today though
and first I'm just going to to convince
you that this is important from a health
perspective to begin with and so I
wanted to do just kind of a baseline
epidemiological analysis to see if we
use traditional methods what pops up
um and so what I did was to compare uh
pollen concentrations from those
monitoring stations uh with some health
outcomes data this is these figures here
show Airborne pollen concentrations over
time and our study period was about five
years from 2016 to the end of 2020 and
this first panel here shows the
concentrations of key press ACA which
includes the Juniper species that I work
with
here the thick black line is the average
across all the stations and the thin
gray lines are the individual stations
and so you can see that there's a lot of
variation
um also note this is a long pen scale
I then compared this with emergency
department visits where asthma was the
primary diagnosis and this and I did
this for uh for three different age
groups young children school-aged
children and adults and
so basically
um
I'm going to just uh skip to the chase
here and show you some of the results on
the x-axis here is the date ranging from
January to December uh the red lines
indicate the number of observed cases
and then each of these colors here
represents attributable risk uh the ones
that I want you to focus on
um are not the viruses although those
are very important but instead the
pollen and you can see these big spikes
in emergency department visits at
certain times of year for tree pollen
and the yellow and then also for
um I've been also some sizable spikes
for uh Q press ACA or right around the
new year
and so
um
so even with these kind of course
exposure metrics we do see some some
strong effects of this tree on emergency
department visits for asthma
I'd also like to take a moment to to
thank the the folks who have been going
out and collecting all this pollen data
like this type of work isn't possible
without them
um so I'm very thankful that they've
allowed their uh years and years of
pollen collection data to be used for
analyzes like these
now I want to turn back to phonology and
that is is one of the the really big
questions here like if we're going to
create these complicated models we need
to know when the pollen is being
released and to approach this problem I
ended up doing a large observational
study where I spent a couple of field
Seasons striving all around Texas
these blue symbols are places that I
visited multiple times and the hollow
symbols are sites that I visited once
per season
when I visited these sites I did things
like uh
collect twig samples and count the
number of pollen cones that had opened
and then Within These pollen cones the
number of pollen sacks that had opened
up and so
um
let's see so here is an example of a
single tree that is visited multiple
times on the x-axis is the date and on
the y-axis is the proportion of pollen
sacs that had opened and so you can see
um in early December nothing had opened
up then around early January it rarely
starts to open on up until
mid-January this tree is basically
released all of its pollen
so so this gets us a certain amount of
the weight there it tells us more or
less when this particular tree is
releasing pollen like generally so
um and so uh so this is useful but I
wanted to take this a little bit further
than just linear interpolation and so I
modeled individual uh the opening of
individual trees
using a golfer's function which is uh in
some ways uh has a fairly similar shape
to a logistic curve
one of the nice things about taking this
modeling approach is that it allows you
to both
um
apply it across a lot of different trees
within a site and then also to multiple
different sites and I did this within a
Bayesian framework which allowed me to
account for missing data in some places
uh and there's a bunch of really cool
statistics that are involved in all of
this and I have like 12 slides at the
end if you really want to get into it
but for now I'm just going to say some
cool Bayesian stats if you're interested
um and with this information we can do
things like uh say the what the season
midpoint is for a site like this one or
for some other site
um in this case if it's one of those
sites where it was just visited a single
Pine season
when we display those season midpoints
geographically you can begin to see some
patterns here uh where the the season
midpoint uh was a little bit earlier for
sites over than say the Eastern uh
range of the species compared to the
Western range of the species
and so I was of course curious about
whether I could predict this and to do
that
um I turned to a bunch of different
environmental data sets one of which was
s map the soil moisture active passive
sensor
and with this
um I was able to begin to try and figure
out what could predict uh
the timing of pollen cone opening for
the species
now one of the the problems here is this
is releasing pollen in the middle of the
winter so we can't use any of those
traditional Frameworks like Growing
Degree Days they just don't really work
and we don't have very good a priori
hypotheses about what periods are
important to the development and timing
of release for this plant and so I
turned to uh in this case to a
statistical approach using the Quinlan
package and R and basically allowed the
the data to speak for themselves to
figure out the the periods of time that
have the greatest influence on this
phenological outcome
and
and this is what this shows it basically
um gives them for allows us to explore
um how how much of the variation we can
predict essentially when we have an
opening wind when we open our
phenological window of impact uh let's
say and uh Springtime versus in the fall
and ultimately
um we can use this to figure out the
predictors that have the the most effect
here uh and those turned out to be soil
moisture which is not a surprise this is
a pretty water limited system
and so these Maps show
um soil moisture from s-map
both in the the first year and in the
second year and then we can compare it
with the timing of uh those seasonal
midpoints for those sites
and you can see there's a fairly decent
relationship here the the sites which
are wetter tend to be releasing pollen
earlier
and then what we can do based on those
relationships is see how that um that
varies we can map that back over into
space and here
is
that same information in an animation
and so the colors here indicate the uh
uh the amount of cones opening on a
particular day each of these frames is
one day starting and the end of the
December we are now into early January
and you can see this wave of uh cones
opening up going from the eastern part
of the state over to the western part of
the state
foreign of course this these seasonal
patterns are important but if we're
talking about atmospheric dispersion
models we can't be content with just
what's happening in a given week we need
to understand what's happening on these
finer time scales the ones that are
relevant to say like a gust of wind
coming through and so I simultaneously
investigated some of this stuff on finer
time scales
and to do that
um
I both took a large number of
observations myself and also started up
a citizen science project
um and I'm not going to focus too much
on the side of the citizen science data
today but it's it's I can tell you that
after driving thousands of kilometers
it's pretty cool to have people just
like going out regularly taking some of
this data which is so useful and
important
um now one of the things that we
measured was just qualitatively how much
pollen came off one of these trees while
it was being observed with a very
technical approach of shaping the branch
and seeing was there a lot of pollen
this is an example of a lot of pollen
um and there's a
I've had four different people tell me
stories about how newcomers to to Texas
have seen the pollen being released from
these trees and thought there was a fire
in life so the the fire departments get
regular calls at this time of year
something's on fire in the woods but
um
okay so what we can then do is model uh
pollen release whether there's a lot of
pollen being released or just a tiny bit
um as a function of things like the the
developmental uh curve of those trees
from before and
and we can also include uh finer grains
environmental data things like
wind speed and humidity vapor pressure
deficit stuff like that
um this is an example from grid mat here
which is a gridded sorts of
meteorological beta uh and this is just
um
each of these different frames here is
just uh let's see this is vapor pressure
deficit from one day to another day in
early January so you can see there's
huge uh the weather changes it's not
consistent one day to another especially
in Texas or I suppose here
um and with that type of information
we can begin to see some patterns uh so
I'm just going to show you the results
for vapor pressure deficit which you can
if you're not familiar with it you can
think of it as
um how the uh
how much drier the air is than a plant
and how much water is being sucked out
of that plant potentially
and then we can so let me Orient you to
some of the results for vapor pressure
deficit on the x-axis here is vapor
pressure deficit
um and this is on the current day here
so on the day of observation and then
these colors indicate
um the the likelihood of there being a
lot of pollen released essentially this
is a relative risk this is using
um the a distributed lag framework uh
which is a pretty cool statistical
approach which lets you both uh have
some flexibility and the the period of
lag as well as the the shape of its
effect
um and it's used in epidemiological
analyzes but it applies pretty well to
the system too so uh what we see here is
when it's drier there's a lot more
pollen being released
um
but we can also do that going back in
time too and so these are so this is the
current day and then up here was a week
ago and up here two weeks ago and we can
see that the
when it was much drier like a week or
two ago at that particular site it's
much more likely to be releasing a lot
of pollen now and so this gives us a way
to kind of untangle some of the uh
relationships and ultimately we can use
this to predict pollen release over time
uh so here this is just that one
particular site
state is on the x-axis and the
probability of high pollen releases on
the y-axis and you can see that there's
uh a lot of variation from one day to
another based on these environmental
variables as well as on the different
um
uh
ripening rates of these different trees
and just to compare our this
to those kind of smooth seasonal Trends
it turns out that these don't work quite
as well for uh we're actually getting at
what's going on so and including the
smart fine-grained data it was really
useful
that being said uh there's a ton of
limitations to this like uh for example
I only went out at night occasionally
and so almost all of these observations
are during daylight more or less and
they're also just a few snapshots of
this process and so what I wanted to to
do was to get at the the full pollen
release uh temporal distribution for
individual trees
oh and so I wanted observations around
the clock and I also didn't want to have
to collect that data myself
um and so what I ended up doing was to
build a device to do this for me and so
I want to introduce you to the pollen
platter uh which is
um something that I built with the help
of set down at UT Austin
the way the splatter Works
um is there's a so it's a box that you
can place underneath the tree there's a
little slit in the box and then some of
the pollen falls through that slit
underneath the slit is a platter which
is controlled by a little microprocessor
and just kind of and it's programmed to
turn at a predictable rate so you can
then see the the areas where there's a
lot of pollen on that platter and map
that back over time
um and so I just deployed these pollen
platters uh a bunch of times bunch of
sites few different treatments and uh oh
and I'd also like to take a moment to
thank Kent for all of his help
processing these samples from Texas
so here is I think
it's the the purse comprehensive
um record of pollen release on these
types of time scales from a wind
pollinated plant which I think is pretty
cool uh and so here we have the the date
on x-axis and the pollen concentration
on the y-axis and you can see that there
is a ton of variation both between days
which we kind of already knew but also
over these fairly short time scales
which means that we can't just ignore
what's uh what's happening on the scale
of hours we need to to take that into
account
element and we can use the same types of
approaches as before we can plug in
different environmental data and use
that to understand the effects of things
like temperature and precipitation and
vapor pressure deficit to create these
models
um on the spine temporal scales
oh one of the the issues that we had
with this though is that
um we're kind of merging together all of
these different processes right there's
a presentation of pollen but then
there's also wind right the wind isn't
always blowing so it doesn't always fall
off immediately and I thought God it
sure would be nice if we could just like
have a reduced wind as a variable and so
Ken and I spent a while this summer
iterating through different setups here
and eventually got something going in
the growth chamber where we have a fan
on a timer to blow it and then we can
have all this in a growth Chambers so we
can alter the things like temperature
and humidity to begin to to do a better
job of figuring out exactly which of
these processes matters when
I also
the pollen platter is great but it they
can be a little bit finicky and it's
also it's not always feasible to place
these out and so uh I also worked with
blue who's an undergrad here uh to see
if we could do time lapse photography to
capture this process of antithesis and
so these are some examples this is uh
plantago landscielada and you can just
see uh
these anthers popping out over time and
blue also built his own little setup for
manipulating temperature and relative
humidity uh and so we can begin to teach
some of these things apart uh and how if
we change humidity in one way how does
that affect the rate of anthesis shown
here as uh both the size of the dot and
the color and we can also see like what
happens when we change temperature when
we change both at the same time and we
can begin to really understand what's
going on here to a greater degree
and ultimately uh the goal with all of
this is to to merge these different
models together to include these
seasonal variables and also to throw in
what's happening on these daily and
hourly scales
um so I was really hoping that I'd have
a little bit of this further along so I
should could show you an animation on
these hourly time scales using some
gridded environmental data but
um check with me again in a few weeks
so these are just a few different pieces
of this process uh for understanding the
uh pollen concentrations over time and
space and their health effects and
um oh I suppose I also wanted to mention
uh pollen production which is an
important piece of this puzzle and also
one which I do not have a good handle on
yet and uh the reason I'm giving this
talk here today is I've been working
with the prospective PhD student who is
going to be applying to the soil and
crop Sciences Etc to The Graduate field
um and Hannah is going to be working on
figuring out how much pollen some of
these trees produce and we're hoping to
make use of the really Stark differences
in color that you see between the male
trees of the species and the female
trees on the left here you can see a
male tree that's this kind of brown
color and on the right you can see a
female tree without any pollen cones
which is green and so we're we're hoping
to use these differences in
reflectance to as a way of kind of
scaling up pollen production for these
trees so we can and we're hoping to do
this with some aerial imagery but we're
also exploring a couple of other
possibilities
um unfortunately this projector is not
really showing the Reds very well so
you're going to have to worry with less
uh take my word for
um some of these trees looking much more
reddish brown than others this is
supposed to convince you that it's very
feasible to do this because there are
these big differences
um but you will have to take my word for
it I'm afraid
and so
um once we can scale up things like uh
pollen production over these large areas
we're hoping to compare them to other
environmental data out of the usual
climatic stuff but also things like soil
nutrients as well
um and the spin we're putting on this
for uh for Hannah's grfp application is
all about the um
climate change and the synchronicity of
plants kind of going into some of the
hypotheses around masting that were
developed for trees
um so there's a lot of basic research
questions which I think can be answered
with these methods too which are pretty
cool but I'm not going to get into them
in too much detail now
there's also some possibilities uh here
for extracting
phenological information from trees
using High temporal satellite imagery
specifically from planet which I think
would be really cool and super useful so
I'm investigating that possibility right
now
so there's a lot of steps to be done
here
um but there's also a ton of potential
for connecting these basic ecological
Geographic and phenological processes
through to their specific effects on
human health and ultimately to figuring
out how we can get this information into
the hands of people so they can do
something about it whether it's changing
their behavior managing their medication
better or whatnot
um and each of these different steps
along the way gets us a little bit
closer to that goal
of course
that's just one species and one state
and so ideally we'd be thinking about
how to do this on a much broader level
and so I've been thinking a lot about
how do we scale up these types of things
to a continental level
and one of the the big answers to that
question involves uh collaboration with
citizen science in particular with the
national phonology Network and
um
yeah so that is something that I'm
actively working on just uh and it turns
out that creating phenological models is
something that you can do with enough uh
enough observations enough environmental
data you can create these models and it
turns out that they do a pretty good job
of predicting uh Airborne pollen
concentrations and I just heard back
that this little paper here
um just has some minor revisions but
that is some of where this type of thing
is going in the future scaling up to
bigger sales so we can make a difference
in more people's lives so with that I'd
like to thank some of the various uh
funding sources that have funded uh both
my postdocs and I'd also like to thank
some of the the folks who have been
involved in this uh throughout the years
especially
um
here in my lab now to Kent blue Stark
and Kyle as well as to some
collaborators elsewhere
um and with that I'd be happy to take
some questions thank you
uh in terms of how after that you'll be
modeling so I was wondering if there's a
way to make this kind of that third
connection automatic with the Machine
Vision or other yeah yeah totally
um so there are some groups working on
um on automating pollen identification
um there is some nice systems over in
Europe that only costs about uh 600 000
U.S right now uh the exchange rates get
at the moment
um so but those are those systems are
very expensive and that makes it hard to
to kind of as scale up with them there's
also a company here in the U.S
um a pollen sense that I've been working
with a little bit and they are trying to
do exactly that uh
using a
real-time data collection
microscopy computer vision and so on
um and so this is an approach which even
if it hasn't hit its full stride yet I
think will be very useful in the future
that being said uh when concentrations
vary by orders of magnitude across like
a kilometer you're never going to be
able to get the the density that you
would need to provide good information
and it's also
um for individual people and so I think
it's going to be play a really large
role in this to have this more real-time
uh data collection
um at the same time we if we're
if we approach this with models we'll be
able to generalize better and to and if
we understand the underlying biology
we're going to be able to to predict
things like uh there not being much
pollen release on January 9th and 10th
things like that
um
[Music]
happens much earlier and perhaps so
slower for this sort of quiescent
and then when the conditions are right
perhaps the BPD is quite high or getting
quite dry and mid to late January then
the the hissing sore amphisis is uh
elicit
so I want you to comment if you would
please on whether or not my
understanding is correct is there a role
to play in flower induction are there
differences in year-to-year variation in
the timing of flower induction or is it
primarily in that and pieces uh timing
that is important yeah I it's it's
definitely all of the above right so we
have the development of these pollen
cones oh and
and that um I'm afraid I don't have any
data on the the development of them I I
think that would be really useful here
for teaching it apart um but uh two
years wasn't enough time to do
everything
um and and so I kind of see this as a a
series of processes kind of like this
Rube Goldberg device of this happens and
then this happens and and some of these
the ones that I've been focused on are
the kind of General uh ripening and then
the processes of uh pollen cone opening
and release but the the development of
them I think uh the fact that is that
soil moisture of in that spring is one
of the best predictors for the
differences in timing implies that it
does have a lot to do with it
um
and I wish I had a plant physiologist to
collaborate with on some of this stuff
do you have a sense for how
yeah
um there's a ton of variation and uh
something like oak trees where when I
showed that example of national stuff at
the end it works great for oak trees
because they tend to release pollen at
pretty similar times of year
um some some types of trees are just way
harder to predict than others uh there's
when there's a lot more variability
between individuals that can really make
things challenging and so I think what
we're going to
end up doing is well at least what I'm
going to end up doing is focusing on the
the most important and easiest species
and uh Genera first and then eventually
tackling these tricky ones
um and and some of these things are
going to be predictable uh but others
could be due to uh genetic variation
things such as are very hard to to guess
about from first principles so
great for some things mediocre for
others it's going to be an awful lot
better than the commercial pollen
forecast so I'll tell you that
there are a bunch of different sources
of information
um the word on the street is that at
least for some of these I can't name
names but some of them use things like
um sales of allergy medication to get a
sense of the timing of this some of them
have access to some real data there are
a few pollen monitoring stations which
uh posts their information directly
online without having to
um and don't require like
it's just generally available so uh
there are a couple of the the pollen
forecasting companies that um are trying
to do some of the science behind this
but
um and
I I'm afraid I can't say too much more
about that other than
um
there's I think currently just no
accountability and so there's not much
incentive for them to make sure that
they're doing things right hopefully
when we get this uh thing up and running
and have a website that says like oh
well this uh this company's model
predicts 12 of the variation like maybe
then they'll have a little more
incentive to do it right
a quick quick question
um clearly when you're looking at pollen
with these trees you're looking at it as
a disservice because you talked about
shade as being hopefully a ecosystem
service I guess my question to you is
given the kind of work that you do have
you been caught in a situation where
you're being asked what kind of tree
should we be planting in this
municipality and if that is kind of a
tricky kind of place to be yes you could
put the street but because it doesn't
produce power but it might not have
other I'm just wondering how are you
navigating this kind of things to me
that you've got a tug of war between
service to service when it comes to
these trades yeah absolutely uh
fantastic question and that's just how
it goes right there are our interactions
with these trees are so multifaceted
there's a hundred different ways in
which uh you interact with the tree
outside of your house even if you aren't
really thinking about it consciously
most of the time and some of these
things are are kind of annoying or
somewhat dangerous like pollen or like a
tree falling on your house
but a lot of them are really good
especially in terms of heat reduction uh
the the psychological benefits the
economic benefits are generally massive
and and so what
I think we need to do is to understand
each of these different
dimensions of it what are the the good
things that a tree would provide and
what are the bad things I don't think we
should just ignore the bad things just
because uh somebody likes trees as much
as I do like no we should we should
weigh all of these things together and
one of the pieces that's really been
missing in a lot of this literature is
understanding the spatial Dimension so
like what are the distances over which
these effects are going to be felt and
and so uh
so I think the the the thing to do is
ultimately to combine all of these
together and uh provide uh folks like uh
Urban Foresters uh and other people
planting trees I mean there's a billion
trees planted each year in the U.S so
this is this is an important question uh
let's give people the information they
need and I don't know maybe by the time
I'm like uh maybe by the end of my
career we'll have some tools which can
do a better job of saying like hey if
you have this spot here what are the
specific ecosystem services and this
services that you would get from
planting uh this and Oak this species of
Oak here versus this species of maple or
whatnot and uh to understand it perhaps
unified through an economic evaluation
framework great
so if there's another question yeah
that once they open they will be solved
like do they release
yeah it's um
so what ends up happening is uh is way
more complicated than I had hoped for
um and it is so there's let me see if I
have um
[Music]
um
let's see I just wanna yeah let's go
here oh and so you can see all of these
individual pollen sacs and so they uh so
there's both these um kind of scales
opening and closing
um and then there are these individual
pollen sacks inside of it once the
pollen sack opens it's opened
um however uh it's often like when
you're looking at a particular pollen
cone or thousands of them
um you see that often
um there are some pounds acts open on a
cone but not all of them
um and so I'm trying to think of
something clever to do to tease apart
some of the uh the processes based on
that information but
um still considering it and part of why
I was asking with the chart we were
looking at where we saw the slides and
then kind of all of them and another
site is I thought like oh did they just
be really it's like the wind on that day
you know like why why you can see
yeah yeah a wind plays a large role I I
can show you quantitatively that yes
there's an effect however it is much
more than just wind
thank you all really appreciate your
time
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu